[Applaudissements]
on pourrait déduire quoi en tant que
femme toi t'es quoi me dois tu es et tu
m'as tu m'as demandé d'être moi je suis
marié même jean michon crétois mais tout
le monde aurait fait seul
[Applaudissements]
je vous en supplie ne dit plus rien
avait sans doute
[Rires]
allez on oublie on oublie bon alors là
il a dit c'est donc là on dirait que les
femmes à voir donc voilà avoir une
certaine dextérité avoir une certaine
dextérité donc voilà à voir du doigté
non mais c'est vrai voilà les femmes on
est des fous voilà c'est tout on oublie
ça voilà le oui c'est vrai voilà donc
merci donc et c'est tout à fait voilà le
tout à fait louable de votre part
gratuit